most dietary supplement delivery systems  now which is generally capsules and  caplets don't get absorbed well by the  body it turns out Nature has given us  the perfect blueprint for a solution the  liposome cell membranes are comprised of  lipid bilayers and we can make these  same lipid bilayers and use them to wrap  around the nutrients we want to deliver  and we can make these so small they get  delivered right in the oral cavity into  circulation before they even get down to  the stomach and these liposomes are so  similar to your cell membranes that they  are incorporated fuse didn't get the  cell membrane while the nutrients are  delivered right into the cell  [Music]